okay all right let's get started so for
people who are joining this livestream
this is a internal design meeting
talking about future features of often
language part of our incremental
language design series that involves
small but collectively important new
features that were looking at for the
language so let's get started with scale
convert so this is a suggestion from a
user asking for a way of converting
these very large names of numbers so
probably the the implementation in unit
convert is not the right way to do it
this could be done in and one of the
week I mean it's the some way if you
type in a number I'm not sure we have
the right people here but I mean if you
type in a number if I say interpreter of
integer five billion or something
don't I get a result no that's
interesting oh maybe it's maybe I have
to say um semantic integer yes I do get
a result there so what is the difference
here is the issue that semantic integer
isn't handling these really big numbers
or what I think part of the idea what is
we have integer name an integer string
which will give you sort of the the long
form name of them but if you want to
convert them on these different scales
you know you you want to say five
billion in millions there's not really a
way to do that it it seems like kind of
a strange operation to me but I can see
for some of these really large scales
it's maybe nice to compare the number of
people who use octave again Chileans can
be counted on the fingers of Noah that's
probably true
um okay so but more you know more to the
point so this case here we have covered
the fact that this doesn't work is
arguably a bug
so Francisco can we handle those types
of numbers with with so you you said if
we can interpret them in generalizing we
have a large sum large numbers to be
that can be interpreted sure if we have
folded certainly these these are things
which as output from off alpha are well
known to be able to be put into output
right so let's see whether we can do it
an input oh we can't well okay so
there's the problem so I think that's
just a bug
um I do think documentation wise for
entered your name we shall so so is it
the case that we are doing this an
integer name if I say entered your name
of you know 10 to the 30th okay we are
doing nice yes and we have only for
English by the way that's something that
is there a word for this in Spanish for
example there are some iterations but
yes yes there are in French and for
these really big numbers I mean that
nobody ever uses I think someone took
the work of translating but no one knows
them free right I mean if I just do a
web search for this yeah there's 10,000
hits for October again Tilian and
they're mostly dictionaries and sites
about naming large numbers this is not
yeah this there's no evidence here let's
just do in I this is a corner case this
is not something that's that important
in my view um I think it is a minor bug
but it could whoever cut back on noise
could you see someone mood um the
let's see I'm I'm um I think we should
consider it a low priority bug for
semantic integer a bit semantics integer
interpreter and leave it at that and
really object to this and make sure
we've documented this part here in the
integer name documentation that make
sense yes okay let us continue then
mixed radix and it's just string yes so
the problem here is a difference with
integer digits so with integer digits we
effectively always prepared with based
infinity so we can't represent any
number however with integer string we
cannot do that and then for example you
see that as long as the number goes
beyond the product of the basis we just
give an error saying okay so the
question is whether we can do better
than that like inventing a mutation to
understand this so in this case with
interested idiots somewhat peculiar way
this has an additional infinity digit as
the first digit exactly yes
so if we have four bases they the result
we get is it has either four digits or
five digits if we need to extend but
never more now is a bit odd but okay but
within to just string because the
Infinity base it's unclear how we would
represent something in the Infinity base
as a string exactly because we have the
limitation of 36 in integer string boy
this is another horrifying corner case
type thing okay what do you propose well
either between extending the notation
like we add some character which says
now we are going to change to decimal
something another question why do we
care I mean in other words we're giving
this message we're saying sorry you
can't represent that number in this
mixed radix space
well I guess these yeah it's a corner
case we just wanted to to to feel a gap
here and because we are starting to
discuss recently this bakes base64 which
goes beyond 36 it feels a bit strange
that we limit ourselves to 36 when we
are going to then use 50 base64 I mean
like the new stuff with hashing you know
new is that in this version I don't even
know if it's in this version but but um
let's say I say hash hello in sha and
and this is not probably um this is
probably not Otto completing yet oops
this should be in the if I'm not
mistaken at least in the prototype
No what's wrong here am I my
misremembering this or is it okay I mean
there's some representation in base64
yes so it's using so limitation of 36 is
because we use the their alphabet
characters and the numbers so 26 plus 10
now in 64 they use the lowercase the
uppercase and the numbers basically for
encoding and okay so the basic point is
what we really need to do here is an
integer string just like in hash we need
this notion of what the encoding
alphabet is right so that that's the
question at the end should we allow
users to specify their own alphabet well
right now we don't oh I see we have pads
the string to be drat so okay so we have
I think the answer is yes but I think we
need to merge this design with the
design of hash now unfortunately we seem
to have this introduced string has the
string on the left with zero digits to
give a string of length let and that's a
useful thing for sure but it could be an
option for this case or you make the we
just take the encoding and then that
digit encoding would be something that
it may be a list or a name it unknown
list like base 64 base 58 whatever I
agree but this relates to what we're
doing with all the base64 encoding stuff
because we've already got a how does
this work we were just looking at this
yesterday don't we have I mean so for an
integer here we have already base64 no
name it base64 us a string
and the slang was also at for example
base 58 which is the one used but
Bitcoin and what pays 58 track well we
wanted to use the check
variant that's right they check that's a
harsh and repents character okay so what
you're saying here is that this is what
you're saying is that the base the be
the base here has a bunch of names and
probably these things are going to end
up having to be named yes and now this
comes from the discussion of mixed radix
the question is if we allow different
digits for different bases perhaps the
base language is what should be
generalized so that mix relics can take
different digits in different bases it
gets a bit crazy but it seems like the
right place to put it because it may be
useful to have for example if I want an
interest ringing in base 30 but with
different alphabet let's say I want to
use only lowercase or only uppercase
whatever that I could put an option with
the list of actual digits I want I think
I agree I think that's useful um but now
this for example this check digit thing
is yet another piece of decoration on
top of all of this right but the icing
goes more with cash than with entire
string really okay it's fine
so integer string so your claim is that
the first step here that what you're
saying is this is really based 58 here
except that doesn't make any sense
because we can't give a base 58 it seems
to me that maybe what we should be doing
is in the case where this is a radix
above 36 I suppose I don't know what
where whatever that we maybe could give
a syntax where it's 58 arrow and then
for that if that's what we think we're
do using we can either have named bases
like base like this thing here you know
quotes base64 if those are named
standards or alternatively just give the
radix and then give arrow alphabet and
then potentially in the case of mixed
radix we could do the same thing with
either inside the mixed radix wrapper or
outside the mixed radix wrapper I see
and all the digits would take characters
from the same effect everyone with their
each Alfred okay yeah in other words it
could go either way
this seems to me I mean if what you want
to do is I mean this to me seems like a
somewhat reasonable I mean we could also
have if we think we're gonna be using it
elsewhere we should I mean these are for
that's going to be messy typically
unless they're a standard they're going
to end up being messy there's an
argument by the way that we should put
in our alphabet function right we're
where we you know currently we have
things like Russian you know if there is
a if there is a notion of an alphabet
where there's a mapping you know from
what on earth Minnie Isis oh I didn't
autocomplete why didn't it autocomplete
did it also complete know how it did
autocomplete I ignored the
auto-completion no matter okay so my
argument here would be that it would be
good to support since since we've got a
whole bunch of you know we've got letter
number right which which supports an
alphabet right letter number character C
alphabet you know English for example
right that whole set a piece of
functionality could also be supported
for if we had named alphabets like the
base 58 you know no words if
had an alphabet called base 58 that
could then be supported with a letter
number and things like that as well
which could be useful
that makes sense to have these lists
publicly available via a search function
that's what I'm saying yes because
because otherwise I mean what we've got
is I mean these are string encodings
we've been sort of circling around in
fact a tie has also been involved in the
string encodings business and maybe he
should be consulted on the C I assume
he's not in this meeting
um okay so let's take a look so for
example if we look at Wikipedia's list
of base 64 right so there's different
schemes that they probably discussed and
see whether they discuss um okay so
they've got a bunch of other weird
random ones of these um binary-to-text
encoding okay so this is this is the
list we've looked at this before
actually I mean I just don't know
whether this is where we want to go
where they're integers string on its own
or whether there's something which has
to go straight from a byte array to one
of these encoding z' am I making sense
yeah what both things seems useful um
the conversion of a number into a well
defined off of it seems something will
define for indigestion yes but I think
also for byte array what's the way of
converting I mean there is a byte array
to string function right
sniff assent and not very useful oh
because those are the actual bytes right
so if I say 160 to 170 here Oh
fascinating
I see so that's a byte array I don't
really know what this is doing here
that's that is by default using a
character encoding which is um so if I
say character encoding ISO well what is
it
ISO latin-1 or something should be a
character encoding oops maybe I'm
expecting maybe it's expecting the
character encoding like that yeah there
we go okay
so how does this relate to what you're
talking about so this is a mapping from
bytes into string characters yeah so
this is probably a base 256 we think
evenly stuff right but so then this
thing here this character encoding is
again something closely related to your
alphabet setup right right look I think
my tentative conclusion is that we could
do something like this in iterative
string we should talk to it I to make
sure that the byte array to string stuff
connects with this properly and in a
sense we can think of it I suppose as a
character encoding in the sense that
what this is saying is you know just
like an alphabet isn't a sense of
character encoding where a is 1 and B is
2 and so on and so I think what what
we're saying here is that there is a
mapping from character encodings and
even we could in principle though it's
kind of silly we could say the isolation
1 character encoding is like an alphabet
except you know where 160 is 165 is they
or something I don't remember this but I
thought that was what it was but no kids
doesn't matter but ok but I think this
is a reasonable way to go with interest
string so why don't you see if that
makes sense and if that's implementable
and go from there as well as inventory
in which of these sort of quotes base 58
and so on we should be doing okay and I
believe it is already looked at some of
that okay yes so the question is that we
are about to start Danny's going to
implement these technologies the
extension to support properties like
nearest and we were wondering which
other properties could be added here in
particular this is perhaps closely
related to ranked max okay so we ranked
max is saying get me the second largest
right thing in that list yes so so
that's a bit like dick largest so the
question cope take largest yes it is
okay so so the question is whether even
the tag largest is going to take
properties whether it should have
apart from index an element yeah but by
the way I'm sorry I just want to raise
this is this a sushma here okay you
notice that these in this documentation
these subsections are open here which
they should not be supposed to work on
it but he hasn't yet needs to be
prioritized okay um
ranked max only returns an individual
value or maybe a span and hands fees
upon you okay take largest returns you
know from here to the top or something
to that effect
mm-hmm these are related but not the
same as what I'm getting at so I'm sorry
would you say that ranked max seems only
to return a particular element whereas
take largest return
they span I believe I mean yes
yeah list of those okay so I mean for
knitting you know obviously they're
related but what one can't rewrite one
in terms of the other very easily okay
right okay just want to make sure I'm on
the right page here right the question
of list ability of ranked Max is an
interesting one seems sensible to do
that I don't know why we didn't do that
in the first place yeah because then
then it will feel closer to take not
just typing with um I think we should do
this I don't see an objection to doing
this you might want to send out
something encore design you just ask
I don't see an objection um okay now
there's the question of what the sub
properties on take largest should be
okay so index would be tell us the
indices that are at which for which we
have so I don't quite understand what
this is so tell us the indices of the
three largest things in this list yes so
this is the general idea of in many
cases we not only want the objects that
debated some property but their position
right and and so this is the way of
getting both them at the same time if we
say element comma index right I mean
arguably you could also want the
difference between the elements and the
maximum or something
although which will be the analog of
distance right yeah
well what would we call that if we were
going to have the distance analog what
would it be called here we can have
index an element or clearly two things
okay so what is rank what would rank to
rank would say I see rank would say for
each element where is it in the ranking
of elements in that list yes it's a big
order but I understand how the ranking
works when there are ties yes well it
will have to do like like rank marks the
second and the third either saying well
the second and the third are the same
now there will be an ambiguity in which
way which one we call the second and the
third the question is does it jump it's
like if we have a ranking it's we've got
the top you know element then we've got
elements 2 & 3 which are tied then is
the next element 4 or is the next
element 3 I think it's four means that
you would put two two twice if they are
if they are repeated I would think yes I
would think that's what we have to do
unless we we have some other if that's
the ranking you know it's it's like if
if there were two people tied for second
place they're both in second place
that's not like second place in third
place but can you try ordering of that
at least you can this one here for
example I think ordering will have a
tie-break yeah
so the sevens are numbered differently
able to dentists one for a ranked type
of thing I'm not sure who say I kind of
like the idea of not breaking ties that
look like they're gonna have something
like ordering which by call it ordering
if we say index and you know if another
one of those properties is simply
ordering then that would be consistent
mm-hmm yes it's like it's also rank so
rank if you asked for the rank
four and five over that list it gives
sevens okay
I see hump
let me think about this for a second so
the issue is let's see do we have a case
where we know we care about this mmm no
I cannot think of one
all right let's punt on this for right
now I mean it seems like there are
because so your proposal is to add rank
and have that be the equivalent of what
ordering wood now what is it exactly
it's it's the yeah it's what ordering
and rank both currently do they consider
that those sevens are four and five yeah
but what would we do to take this list
and replace every element by its rank
how do you do that
right now it's that's ordering now
ordering doesn't oh yes I see what
you're saying I see the same ordering
gives you the rank of each element
exactly now if we took if we took rank
of not least comma this the ordering and
it was list of all it would okay so we
have a comment from our live stream from
Phillips who says a nonparametric
statistics we treat the ordering of
ranking without tiebreaking usually but
not always yeah I mean the the whole
business of ranked max that was set up
for doing nonparametric statistics stuff
um and we've got things like this the
order distribution
this is a whole can of worms
this whole tiebreaking business the
whole can of worms we've also got the
same thing with lists step plots and
things how do we handle it there oh my
gosh okay and how do we handle it in
quantile anybody know I think want R we
have these these parameters right we got
a bunch back on noise by the way guys
there might be me sorry okay so what on
earth are these by the way in modern
times we would probably give string
names for these and we probably should
it that's probably a small items which
might could perhaps take that to the
statistics group that we probably should
also provide string names for these um
we're good to have two different
properties given that we have freedom in
choosing the names I have two different
properties and one breaks times the
other doesn't and when you when you
don't will you skip the dice like for
example having one two to four yeah okay
listen this is a more complicated issue
because it relates to what we're doing
with these other you know order
distribution etc functions I think why
don't you guys try and talk to the
statistics folks and see whether there's
something sensible it's come out of that
and I think this concept that we could
imagine I mean this is also an issue for
sort you know sort has some kind of
defaults tiebreaking that is frankly a
bit a bit you know I'm not thrilled
about it that it has a that at the end
of you know at the end of the day sort
has to sort and
the question is if it has no other means
of tiebreaking what does it do and it
has its own you know internal you know
mechanism for um um you know for doing
that and I think you know sort is one of
the functions where the show kinda has
to go on and has to eventually sort some
of these other things that just involve
giving rankings obviously don't have
that say missed you
just as list step plot doesn't have that
issue in some sense it has to and I even
is that analogy even right that I'm not
sure
in any case okay so look let's have a
separate discussion about about ranking
and tiebreaking okay yeah all right
let's move on here hurry and
differentiation I can guess from that
title what this thing is about yes this
is actually a question from Michael and
no the question is simple so so the
wanted to to curry and D to commute
basically so right now in the current
implementation they don't and if we just
add this line that I added there then
they would my my work so this can be
made to work my worry is that how do the
carriage go yes and this race is the
issue of how do we see a curry a
partially curried function is it is it
still a function or it's already an
expression because it took some argument
so we can for example differentiate with
respect to those arguments that's the
last line and I think that's interesting
question here okay so let me understand
this
so curry F comma two of a so it's
expecting a second argument yes which it
has not been given its give that
argument then it happily does that
it okay Sebastian is can we
differentiate what happens if we
differentiate with respect to the
Phantom second argument we do that with
derivative not with yeah with derivative
we can symbolically represent phantom
differentiation so this thing right but
with D what's it gonna do if there's a
if that limb is missing so to speak you
can't if we do the with respect to B and
and B that's an existing tunnel it will
give just zero
fair enough fair enough it's only in the
case of the symbolically specified
direction but that would work exactly
okay so the question so what's the
question then what's wrong with the
relative acting on the Phantom be on the
Phantom argument well what Michael
wanted is D acting on a which is the new
thing so D is acting D is treating the
carriage function as if it was already
an expression so we have the difference
between functions and expressions yes
okay so his point is okay so currently
it's doing this it's and Michael wants
it to commute with Carrie
exactly under that yeah because we know
the first argument will be a so we can
already do D what are the functions do
we have the two things like derivative
I'm what are the functions are like
functionals that operate in this kind of
way well I can't think of any other this
through which acts on heads but yes
although it's a weak function yes yes
it's it's a it's a map map at head
function right
I mean what about is there any N is
there any notion of n and the question
of whether we can a numeric value and
whether numeric value is preserved in
other words
Yaya here's a question okay so here's a
concrete question so let's say I say
curry of something that as an N hold
some kind of n hold all attribute okay
so what happens with attributes in
general in the carrying world nothing
it's it's I think it's impossible to
propagate them okay so in particular if
F let's say was F was a whole little
function it already lost the game yeah
before it before that happened now what
we were doing in the function function
is to give the attributes explicitly so
in other words in the assembly in the
curry assembly function we will be able
to give attributes yes so let's remind
ourselves what that looks like oh don't
tell me this is broken again I just
don't believe this look at this this is
some goofy thing wow that is super goofy
okay let's try it again this really has
to get fixed
amazing okay well at least I'm now
learning maybe how to get this to work
okay but in any case the curry um okay
so curry has thankfully has only two
arguments all right yes have to compare
it with the function function which has
three arguments oh boy it barely
documents it hmm it's interesting we
don't even give that in the primary
documentation up there arguably we
should move that things it's important
all right
that should I make that move right now
shopping then yeah
you know this word pure function
unfortunately the the common usage is
kind of diverged from what our meaning
of this was but but um I'm going to add
the word anonymous here which has become
the common meaning of pure or anonymous
function well we discussed that again
okay all right perhaps with the first
case is enough if we said that it would
be somewhat clear and something I miss
in the in the details of this function
is the fact that you can use also for
example function null as first argument
and then put a third argument there the
attributes that something is not there
is no example of doing that in what body
what can you do
so you can create an anonymous function
that can for example be something like
this yeah so if you want to use the
third if you want to use the third
argument with rushes you have to put in
all in the first one I did not even know
that I know the last syntax coloring
look maybe the people from from then do
you know that
what's interesting I didn't know I mean
gosh well
we should tell the syntax coloring folk
if they I wonder how long this has been
supported 25 years okay what's not
surprising nobody knew about it's not in
the documentation and okay well why
don't we let me put in a few tries line
why don't we check on core design that
nobody objects to this why don't we get
it sent as colored correctly something
we use in many places when we need
animals functions with hatchets because
this is the only way to do that okay
well who else in this meeting has used
this I have used it yes well I would
have used it right known it existed um
as a pure function that is treated as
having attributes actually the case
desert there's also the case you know
what I should write this down it's just
attr because really there's the case of
a single attribute there
perhaps you can write attrs and then say
an attribute or a list of attributes
well yes elsewhere we can do that as
having attributes okay um so now so that
was a syntax coloring in a perfect world
this would also are we calling it params
instead of logs no you need a body let's
see
why don't we just say in utters can be a
single attribute or a list of attributes
and then that lovely link we need to
copy over I think you are missing Attis
yes all right let's put in this weird
case here function no body
hunters can represents in which the
parameters in body
a reasonable yes
okay but now so this needs some whole
syntax coloring rigmarole okay I'm not
gonna mark this as new at eleven point
three because was probably new in
version 1.2 or something if somebody
wants to do this belong King we could
find out when that was added okay so
well we out here so the question was
whether curry could get a third argument
which is its attributes seems not
completely stupid to me um I'm not sure
we are going to be able to do it because
when we have multiple brackets you're
right you're right you're right
I'm gonna put in a future ice thing here
I agree I don't think we can do it
because I don't think we can do the sub
value we can suspend evaluation for the
sub value exactly thing properly
okay okay that was that yes so then with
an ad for the moment and this extension
for differentiation yeah I think it's
okay
do you think it's okay okay I think it's
okay I mean I but but let's just talk
about anything else like n for example
and how much n gets inside I mean is
Korean n hold function for example it's
not at the moment but it should be
certainly should be because the second
argument needs to be protected it could
be a nine-hole dressed function yes I
think you're right something has gone
horribly wrong with that help system
there but they come ready to prototype
build and I can't spell attributes you
know that did you mean should be a lot
bigger in that case that's kind of
stupid that did you mean is microscopic
there that's something for the Search
Search more if you could take that just
dumb that should be like 17 points
bigger or something because I didn't
even notice it was there um I wonder
whether they are to compete should work
in that field of course it should work
yes
I mean we're working on that okay okay
the problem is that the autocomplete
also you might just remind the search
people about that for this particular
case so I think we're aware of this okay
is there a sequence hold play for curry
I mean it's such a sequence II thing
itself I don't know what the okay so n
hold is definitely something it should
be but because if there are difficult
cases we can use we can just have a pure
function in the first argument and then
we put the
attributes exit down there yes fair
enough but we certainly need to protect
the second argument okay mm-hmm that's
is that okay let me push these
documentation changes back and I think
we are I would hope we would get back to
the main list of ILD priorities but I
don't think we've been able to do that
um but at least we got through this
agenda okay nothing else for this
meeting okay we are probably four people
on the live stream we are probably going
to livestream and next meeting also
which will come up in just a few minutes
and is on the subject of parametrize
gosh I don't know how to describe it
time parameterised objects basically um
okay I'll talk you'll soon see me know
nice things make